I love jumping into problems, when I find
that problem that I really care about,
and I really want to see through,
I can't really focus on anything else.
Commitment is definitely
one way of phrasing it,
I've phrased it as well as just obsession.
And I'll continue to be obsessed with
it until the problem is solved, or
I realize that I just for whatever
reason I'm incapable of solving it.
I'm the son of two Hollywood
screenwriters, they write sitcoms,
so they're comedy writers.
And growing up in a household where
we're always laughing and it was funny,
it was amazing.
They work together and they always work
for themselves and they were able to set
the stage for their own career, and
I really inherited that heavily from them.
When I was a lot younger, I liked playing
video games on the computer, but I wanted
to be able to modify the video games or
maybe even make my own video game.
And I realized the tool required
to do that was programming, so
I was able to teach myself how to program.
And seeing the advancements around
programming, especially with artificial
intelligence, made me realize that there
were tremendous opportunities in a wide
variety of industries where you could
apply these programming tool sets.
[SOUND] There's really two themes in my
life that I think tie everything back
together, one of those is,
human nature and human psychology.
The other major theme is this idea of
learning the tools to create things,
really revolve around technology and
programming and
understanding new tech as they emerge.
I was observing the crazy advancements
in artificial intelligence,
deep learning computer vision.
And realized that if we were to use
these extremely intelligent computer
systems to automatically identify
things like guns and knives,
we don't have to rely on human beings
staring at these images to do.
Synapse technology provides
automated detection capabilities for
X-ray security checkpoints, so
we automatically detect threats like guns,
knives and ammunition, as opposed to
having to rely on human operators.
[MUSIC]
We ran a study just to give you a sense
of how improved the numbers are, and
we gave somebody who's never seen one of
these X-ray security machines before.
And we compared that to
someone who's certified and
trained on these X-rray machines.
The person who's never seen
this X-ray machine before,
but was aided by our software,
was able to catch twice as many threats as
the person who was trained to catch them.
If we can keep one more person from being
shot in one of these horrific acts of
violence, to me that is
essentially mission accomplished.
>> Rather get pushed back-
>> I graduated MIT in three years and
I knew that I wanted
some kind of fourth year,
I found Stanford Business School and
I thought what could be better?
It felt immediately relevant to what
I was working on at the company,
being surrounded by lecturers and
professors and teachers and guess I felt
like I had that love and support from some
of the classes and the experiences here.
It suddenly made me realize just
how valuable this place is, and
how much I was able to get out of it.
I learned more during my MBA two year
than I ever could have at my company
alone over a decade of work.
My parents, from an early age,
always said,
you can do anything you want in the world,
but be your own boss.
And that's always really
resonated with me, and
I've always followed my passions and
done exactly that.
What gets me excited every day and
makes me want to wake up and
go to work is feeling like I'm
solving genuine problems in the world.
Whether that's in this case
making the world safer place or
whatever else it may be,
that's what motivates me every day.
And that's what gets me excited and
that's where I feel like there's just
tremendous opportunity in the world.
[MUSIC]